I love looking beautiful and what woman
doesn't want to look beautiful you know
even while you're in prison you try to
keep yourself up cuz it helps you
because you don't want to lose yourself
you can actually just lose yourself in
there that's Debra which is not her real
name she's been in and out of Prisons
for thirty years and during a stint in
Debra recalls spending almost two months
in the Shu it's a special housing unit
otherwise known as solitary confinement
I ask what am I going to shoot shut up
then I get inside they need unhandcuff
you and strip you and everything then
they handcuff you again after you get
dressed and on the way walking to the
room
walk so I'm walking but I don't know
which way to go I don't
I made a wrong move before I know it I
had a officer with her knee in my back
and another office on one side and
another officer kicked me I know
everybody has she heard me when I
screamed
Debra says she was brought to this shoe
for wearing the wrong boots and after a
week in the shoe she was charged with
disobeying an order during her admission
into the shoe itself she was sentenced
to 60 days you're going to room it's
empty it's just a the bed a thin
mattress a pillow that's flat you sit
there in your wait you get two pants two
shirts and underwear you get a shower
every of the day weekend not at all a
man can go without washing maybe a day
but we can't I'm sorry I know I can't I
can't do it she don't get no deodorant
no lotion your skin dries up your feet
the elbows your knees when you go to
prison you can put a relax in your hair
so that new growth comes up there's two
different textures so it cracks because
it's so dry or you if you want to put
butter in your hair because that's the
only grease you have and hopefully that
you get butter on a tray if you don't
get no butter all noticed as a dry J but
if you have your ministration and you
need sanitarium that's where the problem
comes in every day at four o'clock the
bolsa comes first before the truck comes
she says oh we don't have sanitarium
I'll give you an extra tissue and you
could go two days without any sanitary
using tissue
it's like oh god another day no no I had
to sleep unless you sleep you sleep it
away and that's a state of depression
and then some nights with the nights you
don't sleep you just have so many
thoughts you it's like your mind is just
racing Racing racing you hear everything
you hear every sound if someone's
walking if somebody's coming or if
somebody's coming you sitting in there
oh my goodness
why didn't come in this way you know you
always hear screaming issue just
screaming I can't take this day I got
out my legs I couldn't really walk
because so sore from just being still I
mean when you come out your skin looks
so horrible you're so dry I lost a good
20 pounds you feel separate from
everybody
you don't feel but you'll feel a part of
the population
I'm went back the next day I walked off
my unit and went in another year knowing
that I can go back to shit and it's
crazy you want to go back in we you
don't want to be you know I just want to
be alone
you